everyone who's anyone in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe showed up for the
final fight in Avengers endgame
including one character you most likely
didn't spot several eagle-eyed fans
discovered that none other than Howard
the Duck makes a cameo appearance during
endgames climax a master of quack fool
well not exactly that one this one the
anthropomorphic duck pops up after
Doctor Strange Wang and dozens of other
mystic sorcerers open up portals for the
heroes who were dusted in Avengers end
game to step through and join the battle
against Thanos his sinister Black Order
minions his alien army and his massive
ship Howard isn't easily located in end
games final fights if you don't know
where to look for him right is hope Van
Dyne steps into frame Howard can be seen
on the lower right side of the screen
passing through the portal as part of a
group that includes several members of
the guardians of the galaxy series
Ravagers coming to earth to settle an
interstellar score with Thanos if you
blink you'll miss him and a lot of
people did
Howard's cameo and Avengers endgame
raises a big question was he among the
people decimated when Thanos snapped his
fingers at the end of infinity war or
did he manage to survive the mad Titans
mass murder
apparently Howard the Duck was one of
the lucky individuals in the universe
who were spared with Joe and Anthony
Russo confirming to the Huffington Post
that quote he survived
created by writer Steve Gerber and
artist Val Merrick Howard the Duck as a
self-styled master of martial arts who
has an undefined grasp on magic despite
those limited abilities he claims to
possess as well as the frequency with
which he's piled around with Marvel's
mightiest he's rarely shown as
possessing any typical superhero powers
this is different when he suits up as
the iron duck gaining superhero
durability and strength as well as a
flamethrower on each arm
however Howard is just Howard an endgame
so we can't say for certain how helpful
he might have been in the fight fans
first saw Howard in the MCU in 2014's
guardians of the galaxy in which he
appeared as a living part of the
collectors museum alongside fellow
easter-egg cosmo the space dog
what do you let it licky like that for
gross seth green provided the voice for
the CGI character then again lent his
voice to howard for 2017 s guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 in that film howard was
seen having yet another dream this time
on the icy planet contract CEO while
flirting with a woman you're outta luck
until you've gone done these appearances
in the guardians franchise were
reportedly intended to lead to a part
for Howard the Duck an infinity war but
sadly the cameo never happened speaking
in an interview with fandom Anthony
Russo explained Howard the Duck was in
one draft of the script Howard the Duck
actually had a really good scene we were
going to cameo Ken Jong with Howard the
Duck that was a much beloved scene by us
but it just didn't end up fitting at all
according to Joe Russo the scene
involved Peter quill trying to track
down some information from Howard the
Duck on some outlier planets and
interrupting him during a poker game
though neither Howard the Duck nor Ken
Jong made it into infinity war they both
had some screen time and endgame Howard
showed up at the tail end of the movie
while Jong made a cameo early on playing
the security guard who helped Scott Lang
get out of the storage facility in San
Francisco for a while now there have
been whisperings of the possibility of a
new Howard the Duck movie which would
mark the second film based on the
wisecracking Duck after his 1986 debut
back in 2017 Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige teased the future for Howard
in the MCU saying you know the fun thing
about Howard is he shows up where you
least expect him who knows where he's
gonna show up next check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite comic
book characters are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]